autos carbonizados casas destrozadas por
los misiles pintadas de la letra Z del
ejército ruso la guerra en Ucrania está
dejando decenas de pueblos arrasados
casi completamente deshabitados por la
población civil como esta aldea en el
donbas
Antón trabajaba como guardia de
seguridad en un complejo turístico del
pueblo hasta que empezó la invasión
ahora es soldado y lucha la cercana
alssk regresa aquí para ver lo que queda
en pie y dar comida a algunos ancianos
que no quieren irse
hemos evacuado a casi todas las personas
que conozco y ahora esto se ha dejado
así no veo razones para que algo se
reconstruya Aquí no hay nada que
reconstruir creo que se quedará de esta
manera
aquí hay casi exclusivamente militares y
el escenario es de destrucción total las
casas que vemos están calcinadas
arrasadas hay Muy pocas personas en las
calles solo pasa vehículos que
probablemente se dirigen a los
principales frentes de batalla que están
a pocos kilómetros de aquí
muchos de los pueblos fantasmas están
cerca del frente o Fueron retomados por
Ucrania después de meses de ocupación
rusa en esta aldea vivían 1300
habitantes pero la mayoría la abandonó
tras los primeros ataques tetiana es una
de las pocas personas que no se han ido
un reloj y una radio que funciona mal
marcan el paso de sus días
A dónde podríamos ir tenemos aquí
nuestra tierra nuestros tractores en lo
que necesitamos para nuestra granja
También tenemos tres vacas que son como
parte de la familia Cómo podríamos
abandonarlas
Y qué otro tipo
al marido de Tatiana lo diría una mina y
el esposo de su amiga lo mató un misil
ella ahora sobrevive sin gas
electricidad y agua corriente y con el
miedo en el cuerpo